you know my last video i declared that
samantha b is the worst feminist
comedian of all time in the matchup
between her and uh and feminist comedian
lily singh but i think as spending more
time reflecting on it and i i realized
that we we have to give chelsea handler
and hannah gatsby the chance to you know
really fight it out i think it's not
fair i'm all about equity and inclusion
and so i think we have to include them
in this especially hannah gatsby she
needs to be in it so today we're going
to go watch a couple clips from chelsea
handler and hannah gatsby to see if they
have what it takes to unseat samantha
bee from her throne as the worst
feminist community so first let's uh
let's go back again if we must and watch
chelsea handler this is so aggressively
unfun it's almost impressive so a few
months ago i embarked on a mission that
i knew from the beginning would be would
be difficult but has proven far more
challenging than i ever anticipated it's
the sort of mission that tries your
souls shows you who you are what you're
made of test your medal
the mission is to laugh at a joke told
by a feminist comedian
[Laughter]
are you serious now to be clear here
just to be just to be just so we can get
all the technicalities clear the goal is
is is not to laugh at a feminist
comedian because we can all do that
that's very easy to do you can easily
laugh at them the goal is to laugh with
them
to laugh at their material to laugh when
it seems like they want you to laugh and
in the way they want you to laugh so uh
so far i've tried to laugh at jokes from
samantha bee and hannah gadsby if you
watch those videos you know that i i
tried my hardest i did i dedicated
myself to the task
and just came up empty i found myself
not only not laughing but in fact nearly
weeping as i as i stared into the bleak
abyss
where laughter and joy and humor dies it
was a it was a deeply chilling and
unsettling experience
but now we're going to try it again i'm
going to give this one more try this
time with chelsea handler now chelsea
handler is an interesting case because
she reminds me a little bit of like your
eccentric childless aunt who always
smells vaguely of cat litter and
chardonnay i'm a little burnt out so
sometimes don't shoot me i have a glass
of wine with buster here
and she has a boyfriend with a ponytail
who she invites to thanksgiving and he
tells you about his weird hobby like
collecting gerbils or something this
analogy is maybe getting a little bit
too specific i don't know
the point is chelsea handler is weird
and sort of sad
but not often funny at least that's how
she comes across and you know i say this
admittedly as someone who watched
chelsea handler one time for four
minutes
15 years ago when she was on the what
was it the entertainment channel and i
had her on tv because i was looking
under the couch for the remote so i
could change it and in that time that's
like the only time i've ever really been
exposed to her comedy so um i made a lot
of judgments based on that experience
maybe they were unfair judgments and so
now we're going to give this a try let's
let's try to laugh let's go and we'll
start here with i think this is one of
her more recent routines
and let's just uh let's see if we can
get a chuckle out of this and then he
wanted to know about my family history i
was like that's not what this is about
nothing to see there
i was like my brother died when i was a
little girl my mom died like eight or
ten years ago my dad's a huge pain in
the ass so hopefully he'll wrap things
up this year
and i said and quite frankly like i'm
ready to wrap it up too
i said dan i'm not suicidal you don't
have to worry about it but people say
life is too short i think it's too long
like there's so many annoying people out
here and i just can't deal with it i
said i'm losing my patience okay so this
isn't
comedy so much as it's a suicide note uh
there's there's literally no joke here
she's just talking about how much she
hates her family and her own life and
wants to die and the cackling audience
is laughing yeah life is horrible i'm in
despair
good one horrible life this is great
stuff like i hope the people in the
audience never volunteer at a suicide
hotline that's all that's all i'm saying
it's just it's a very troubling reaction
but let's uh maybe it gets funnier let's
keep going i need you to help me with my
lack of patience
and he said okay give me some examples
of your lack of patience and i said okay
fine i was at a table like this probably
a little bigger with three of my
girlfriends before my session that day
with dan my girlfriend orders a turkey
burger no onion no bun no cheese that's
fine we live in l.a
so the server comes over with his hands
full with four plates
and comes over and we're all sitting at
him we're not even talking
and he says turkey burger who ordered
the turkey burger no onion no bun no
cheese
and my friend is just sitting there like
stevie wonder playing the piano
[Laughter]
and he says it again louder turkey
burger no onion no bun no cheese and
this is her
i go hey you go
and i thought my jokes were bad all
right so again i'm not sure where the
joke is supposed to be located here and
i'll let that play for a little while
because i was just i was sort of waiting
um for the joke there isn't this isn't
even try to laugh anymore this is fine
the joke it's like where's waldo the
challenge is just to figure out where
the joke is
i mean forget about actually laughing i
don't even know where i'm supposed to
laugh the audience on the other hand
they just laugh at everything
i mean this woman busts out a a stevie
wonder joke in the year 2020 and the
audience acts like it's the funniest
thing i've ever heard maybe next you can
make a joke about telemarketers
something really topical hey what's the
deal with telemarketers huh ever heard
of these people telemarketers so
annoying the audience would love that
that would that would kill this audience
and then of course at the end of the bit
the punch line i guess is that chelsea
handler is a horrible person which i've
been perfectly willing to believe she's
screaming at her friend in a restaurant
so what we've learned is that handler is
depressed
miserable suicidal and on top of it a
terrible friend these are all excellent
things to say
to your therapist
it's just
not fit for a comedy stage that's my
only point
if you feel like you're not getting the
respect you deserve in life um well that
might be because you don't have a title
in front of your name that uh causes
people forces people to respect you and
here's here's something that you could
get you could get established titles uh
your very own proclamation like i have
declaring that you are a lord or lady
and you have this and you will gain the
respect you deserve i guarantee you all
you need is this one square foot plot of
land in scotland and established titles
is a project based on a historic
scottish custom where landowners are
referred to as lairds or lords and
ladies in english in your title pack
which i hold in my hand here you'll
receive at least one square foot of
dedicated land on a private estate and
an official certificate with a crest
your certificate will include a unique
plot number with which you can see the
exact location of your land with this
certificate you could officially change
your name to lord or lady and you get on
your credit card you're playing tickets
so this is like a legal name change i am
legally officially
lord matt walsh lord best-selling
children's author matt walsh established
titles is having a great limited time
sale so go to
establishtitles.com matt walsh to save
10 off today remember to use the
discount code matt walsh or just click
the link below that's established
titles.com matt walsh or just click the
link below yeah the one thing you
remember as as you watch chelsea handler
again is just how depressing she is to
listen to
uh this is someone who's
living an utterly empty life in
existence and living it in front of
everybody and for our amusement and
somehow it's it it doesn't it doesn't
even manage to be funny somehow i'm not
even sure if uh if we should have
included her in this matchup she isn't
trying to make a joke really she's just
trying to make us all depressed so so i
i don't think she has what it takes to
unseat samantha be let's uh let's go to
hannah gatsby and see if she has what it
takes a few weeks ago we began a journey
together i want to laugh at a feminist
comedian not at them i mean i i can
laugh at them that's very easy to do
but with them i want to find a funny
joke told by a feminist comedian
and laugh at it you
will
fail
that's my goal in life that's the only
thing i want to achieve before i die
i've done everything else
that i want to do sadly enough this is
the last thing so first we tried
samantha b that was a miserable failure
uh didn't work out so today we're going
to bring out the big guns hannah gadsby
okay hannah gatsby's the acclaimed
beloved critical darling the best
feminist comedian currently on the scene
i'm told so we're gonna watch some of
her clips and uh see if we can do this
you know can i laugh at a hannah gatsby
joke can we laugh
let's find out together come along
friends
forget i did that sorry
[Music]
[Applause]
now i want to tell you a story about a
terrible conversation i had at the dog
park once this bloke just walks up to me
i mean he had a dog he wasn't just being
creepy he had context
and i want to tell you this it's not
pertinent to the story but i want you to
know his dog had shoes on
and his dog did not want to have shoes
on because he was doing that like
and it was a whippet situation and
they're shaking at the best of times so
we don't know why are they cold or they
nervous we don't know but it was like
just it was a lot now it's not important
to the story but it was a lot in my
periphery so i just want you to know
added stress okay
well you know a dog with shoes that's uh
see that's kind of funny i'm i'm not a
laugh thing i'm not gonna you know not
laughing level but i mean actually
seeing the dog with shoes that would get
a laugh at me if she had a if she had a
picture she could have showed us you
know the visual probably would have
helped
but uh
simply mentioning the dog with shoes
isn't enough but i'm
i'm on the verge of laughing okay
the dog with shoes okay she's loosing me
up a little bit
i i'm ready to laugh i want to laugh i'm
in a laughing mood now i'm thinking
about dogs with shoes and now she just
has to go in for the kill so let's let's
see let's see what she's got now this
was my uh friend's icebreaker we'd never
met this was his icebreaker he said did
you know
it takes less muscles to smile
than frown
now the men in the audience are sitting
there going oh you've experienced an
isolated incident
and the women are sitting there going
and non-binary folk are like is that a
hard day for you is it
damn it
she squandered it you squandered it
hannah you you i was ready to laugh i
was you had me you had me
why hannah why i mean
now she's going into the absolutely
insufferable feminist harangue about
being told to smile
and of course she throws in the thing
about non-binary folks because you know
she can't make a man vs woman joke
without acknowledging the invented
non-binary category
and that's good
obviously because diversity inclusion
political correctness all the stuff that
makes comedy great
okay dare i even continue playing this i
have a bad feeling now i've just before
i was filled with hope dog with shoes
now she's going into the feminist thing
uh i should have been prepared for this
it is a feminist comedian after all i
wasn't ready it turns out
i'll play a little bit more let's see
how much more we can stomach now as far
as icebreakers go it's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
one basically what he's saying is your
face is wrong can you change it like
honestly and even if i was gave him the
benefit of the doubt right and truly
believe
that energy consumption was his chief
concern that he was just looking at me
going if only she knew
she could live her best life she could
get so much more out of a day if only
she knew like even if i believed that
the thing is i was neither smiling nor
frowning
my face was neutral which takes
all muscles
like and now i am aware that my neutral
face is not particularly chipper
like i do look like someone stabbed the
potato with a spoon upside down honestly
like
no muscles
neutral now i have resting face that's
what it's called it's what's
colloquially known as resting face only
women have resting [ __ ] face men simply
have very important thoughts you best
not interrupt them having like honestly
no one has ever gone up to a man what is
a stranger and gone cheer up love may
never happen no
okay all right just stop i can't this
this
i mean i'm waiting for the joke here i'm
wait the the potato what is that i
potato with a fork in it upside down
i don't know um
she is a communi comedian right so this
there's supposed to be some humor but
it's not really happening instead she's
just venting about a perceived personal
slight
i feel like this is 2003 and i'm
listening to somebody read their live
journal entry to me out loud
and can i just say for the record
for all you women out there just so you
know a little bit of mansplaining okay
actually you are not being specially
targeted when people tell you to smile
you really aren't men do get the same
thing all the time so hannah says no one
would ever say this to a man yes they
would actually they do people say to me
all the time
if you can imagine
i don't like it it's annoying but then
again i don't like it when anyone says
anything to me about anything ever so
i'm not the best judge but the only
reason
why you ladies think that the smile
thing is sexist and that you're being
specially targeted is that you ladies
are the only ones whining about it now
i'm going to go off on my own harangue
there are many things that feminists
complain about where they they think
that women are the only ones that deal
with it
no it's not that women are the only ones
that deal with it it's just that women
are the only ones who complain about it
all the time everybody else we just keep
it to ourselves
so you know when someone says that to a
man we just shrug it off and go about
our day meanwhile someone says it to
hannah gadsby and she does a she does a
netflix special about it my god this is
pettiness on steroids and i say that as
someone who has written multiple
thousand plus word articles complaining
about people who don't put their
shopping carts away in grocery store
parking lots there is no greater
evidence of the of the disintegration of
human society than shopping carts that
people just leave all over a parking lot
so i know something about petty whining
and this this out does even me all right
let's uh
let's try another one and they can put a
stand in because i won't hold things
this shape
anymore i know who i am
i know my strengths
because she's a
she's a lesbian i don't know did you get
it did you get the joke there
it's the
no no no no no hold on listen listen
just to test up did you get it i don't
think you got it it's she's a lesbian
so
she only mentions it 19 times per minute
when she's on stage so you might you
might not have picked up on it lesbians
lesbians lesbian lesbians lesbians
but yeah she is a lesbian that's the
joke there yeah that was uh that that
one is
especially painful i don't know why i
keep torturing myself i went through
this once and now we're going back again
this is how i like to spend this is how
i'm
this is how i'm bringing in the new year
not exactly on a good foot
so would i say that hannah gatsby
deserves the crown for worst feminist
comedian
over samantha b
tough call but i think at the end of the
day
you got to give it to hannah gatsby so
congratulations hannah you are literally
in this case actually the worst